today's topic
[Music]
all right and then we got this man over
here who's the guy on the left look like
he's got an interesting look
he looks like riley dennis
which means that he looks gorgeous
yes or no i'm not engaging in any form
of transphobia so
that's all you bro that's not trans
nothing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[ __ ] tell me i look like whoopi
goldberg that ain't nothing no no
you can't take it back man did you think
man you can't take it back
all right you want me to go first this
is salem he has like a 96 like mustang
convertible
and it's just fun to just go kick it and
cruise around so he uses me for my car
yeah so this is riley
uh he used to be a pro finger deck
oh
and everything as far as music goes like
jamming with him is always a good time
things like that
[Music]
it's happening yeah
is my face really red no and my hands
are a little clammy but it's all right
these guys look like the type of dudes
to be like like if one of them got in a
car accident and couldn't use his hand
the other guy would be like do i'm gonna
give you a hand job bro
like do you need help with something
like like he got that kind of closeness
hi hey hi um our ideal first date would
be
a picnic at by lake and i don't know
we'll eat like a truck booty board or
something
and like be bracelets and maybe like
paint something
yeah yeah yeah maybe with the side of
chlamydia how do you feel about that
you're a five today bro
there's not gonna be a question what are
you talking about
they're gonna have a charcuterie board
you know you don't like charcuterie
i like shakitsuri oh oh yeah talk to us
in french let's go
i like i like the shakitri you know i i
i to be honest with you
when english people say charakuri
whatever the [ __ ] they say i'm like yo
man
stop shaking i say the thing proper yeah
can you give him a full phrase in french
the americans want to
cream their pants huh
what'd you say i said could you
i just heard her cream my pants i'm like
i said kitchen
i said i said could you say a full
sentence in french
because the americans want to cream
their pants
okay you did say greek defense i thought
you were talking about uh
um
for all the people asking for subtitles
you're not going to get them
that's what happens when you're american
yeah yeah everyone else speaks multiple
languages
except you yeah yeah land of the free
yeah but you're not free of ignorance
[Laughter]
okay so we were thinking that we would
go horseback riding on the beach
i was thinking about it and i could
definitely see you guys on some really
pretty horses yeah i have a horse so i
got a couple hats okay
it's real it's happening we're getting
sushi orange juice
and we're gonna have a great time go to
an abandoned building and risk uh
getting arrested for trespassing oh word
yeah a little bit of spice
yeah we start with a bar crawl and then
we're gonna go to the beach
okay all right yeah that's yeah i mean
we're both sober but yeah we'll go with
you
so every girls the guys are gonna be
like yeah totally yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude i could see you know
what walk half a mile and then
throw myself off a bridge yeah yeah yeah
i could see myself doing that
what you want to put a boot up in my
butt
yeah yeah yeah i mean
yeah dude like i'm free around four
what what is that eat fruit roll ups and
fruit gushers out of your ass
i could do that yeah sure yeah yeah
whatever these girls are gonna say
you gotta gonna be like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know did you just fly off like a bird
what happened to that bird he just
pulled a bird man
yeah what happened to that boy
[ __ ] that was good all right let's keep
watching so we're both really big
foodies so our first ideal
double date would be like finding a new
restaurant to eat at parmesan fries
ooh yes hot little sugar yeah which is
good food the good stuff sugar
if we're gonna be bonnie and clyde i
need to know were you the driver or the
shooter
okay for sure yeah whatever you need i
mean yeah he's the driver for sure
uh whatever like both you know i mean
like i'm kind of like gender neutral or
whatever
[Laughter]
i can't do my character so it's just
like it's just
he's got like such a gender-neutral vibe
to him you know pretty lookout
like cliffs maybe we love um laying in
grass
yeah then we'll watch an anime movie
afterwards demon slayer just coming out
i'm not even gonna french with a girl
who said demon slayer like yo holla at
your boy that's a
she got some good taste so you know she
already knows
that's some good taste in there there
you go you already know you're
saying you already know that's a good
anime a lot of people didn't like the
mound of manga and
i thought it was fantastic and then for
night time we would go stargazing and do
you guys know the game like we're not
really strangers
no oh okay it's like a card game that's
meant to like cause deep conversations
it's just a good question yeah
[Music]
sorry jessica and rachel have a good
time they're not as big as a foodie as
we are but i guess we're just going to
go out and get some food afterwards with
each other you know besties
that was terrible that sucks
like i'm like shaking so much you're
like
this whole time i've been like
[Music]
hey guys this is miranda i've never met
somebody who's such a badass
has such a good and pure heart and she
inspires me to be more confident this is
kiana she is
literally the best die hard ride hard
friend you could ever ask for
how many times you think we're gonna
hear literally today
we've already heard it too much
literally not to mention she is the wife
of the party anywhere we go
if keon is there it's going to be a good
time thank you
that's cute betsy informational
nah nah nah you're moving mud no y'all
doing the mostest
this is shania one of the cutest people
ever in her face i
i can't um also extremely affectionate
she'll always be hugging you and telling
you she loves you
this is michelle she will match you on
any energy if you want to be like scream
singing she will be there with you
if you want to like cry and just have
like a really deep conversation she'll
be there with you as well
you know what it makes me think of what
show and tell that's cool
okay so this is my my toad uh it doesn't
do much
but i think it's super cute he's my best
friend imagine two
two guys doing this hey yo that that's
my [ __ ]
yo turn around show them your head no no
no real talk bro
let me actually turn around because i've
never seen the back of my head before
let me
just how does it look to you
it looks like your forehead
when you got someone's forehead you
ain't got no backhand
[Music]
[ __ ] there's so much front it's just
neck in the back
that's right like jerks yeah this is bad
yeah i feel rotten inside
sorry guys yeah sorry no hard value
i don't we're just looking to find walls
i hope so
that is the sitting pose of every male
who identifies as gender neutral because
you can't say your gender neutral
and man spread you got to pick one or
the other
okay cool how's it going pretty good i
don't really know what we're supposed to
talk about
hey guys how's it going good are you
guys
good good good yeah this has been a
weird saturday but hey it's the name of
the game i guess
yeah yeah you guys have all been cool
and stuff like that yeah oh yeah i know
you guys are cool too yeah
okay no also your guys's hair is like
super cool
oh my gosh we were talking about it
backstage and said he's got like the
alice cooper thing and i got like
all in the 70s type thing yeah we're
finishing up at usc
so we're cool i studied business she's
chemical engineering
smarties what are you guys doing yeah
i'm an illustration major uh and i i
play music yeah and then i
do models i'm sorry i clocked that photo
on the right
and i'm like i shouldn't even be
laughing because that should have been
the outfit he came in with
you know those people who model and like
to dress like they look homeless for no
reason because that's like the new
fashion trend
it's the new kanye thing oh my god let
me just wear a trash bag i'm [ __ ]
such an artist
we're in a band we actually formed an
impromptu band a few weeks ago with some
friends oh hell yeah you guys play
she's basically a musical prodigy guys
like she's saying she plays piano she
kills it
that's so sweet thank you no we should
do a jam session
yeah we play pretty much everything yeah
you can go no go ahead go ahead no it's
okay it's hard i would go for hair but
you guys both have awesome hair
[Laughter]
i'd probably go for you yeah there we go
i like really short hair
amazing choice thanks guys appreciate it
sounds good all right thank you guys
nice meeting you both yeah thanks for
talking all right nice meeting you guys
what's so awesome i think we like what
and then we were just like
super frazzled so yeah i didn't even
like think about like oh my goodness
what are like things to talk about it
was like talk and i was like
yeah are people always this awkward on
the speed dating type stuff
or is it just us yeah
okay so the first pair that you've
talked to
is pair one no the second pair you
decide
on the count of three i want you both to
say
either one or two three two
one two oscars
tell them
which one is it you guys you guys are
the final couple yeah
you guys so cool that's so sweet
let's jam yeah let's jam i'm down do you
guys like want to exchange phone numbers
or something
okay definitely my phone's literally not
on me i can go i'll go grab my phone
wait this is so exciting we should
definitely make a group chat and get it
going
yeah can you play the drums i can yeah
we're trying to learn
oh yeah yeah if you can count to four
you can kind of do it
okay my mom drum [ __ ] we could drum
together
like you know what i have a stick you
have a stick
and you know we stick together
anyways uh [ __ ] do you do you
uh play the bass yeah [ __ ] i play the
bass i love the bass you know which bass
i love best
third bass you see what i did there
yeah that's great you know what that
guitar is [ __ ] electric like both of
us
oh [ __ ] dude that's like a totally like
literally
like you know literally like okay okay
okay i can't i can't i can i can't do it
i can't do it
the thing about jubilee sometimes they
find like ordinary interesting people
and other times they find like french
folks which is interesting to watch
sometimes
it's just i think californian young
people are just so cringe
so that's probably it's just something
different something to experience
something that's out there but i'd say
cringe too but hey
but uh but yeah that's it for today's
video did you guys enjoy or did you guys
not who would you have picked whatever
it is you want to say
yeah we agree with everything
[Music]
oh